je me rappelle que le taxi nous déposait
là
et ont traversé par ici mais c'était pas
aussi aménager comme ça avant été motif
c'est la première fois qu'il revient ou
chemin Roxane originaire du Togo il a
traversé la frontière pour demander
l'asile en août 2017 on arrive on
descend avec nos bagages on nous
arrêtait on savait pas combien de temps
ça allait prendre si on allait être
accepté ou non il sera retenu 10 jours
au douanes avant d'arriver dans la
région de Montréal ce parcours il le
raconte dans un livre qu'ils viennent
publier
immigrants ou demandeur d'asile on va
vous demander de sorte de faire de
l'entretien ménagé de travailler comme
agent de sécurité ou d'aller dans des
choses très rapides pour gagner de
l'argent mine de rien on a quand même
des expériences de travail des
expériences de vie des compétences qu'on
peut mettre à contribution Marjorie
Villefranche à bombe dans le même sens
son organisme a aidé de nombreux
demandeurs d'asile arrivés par le chemin
Roxane ils ont du sacrifier ce qu'il
savait déjà c'est à dire leur métier
leur expérience etc depuis 2017 des
vagues de migrants sont entrés au pays
par le chemin Roxane cette année ce
nombre a atteint des records conséquence
je trouve que
l'idée qu'on avait d'une personne qui
demande à asile c'est une personne qui
demande à être protégée et comment se
fait-il que maintenant quand on parle de
demandeur d'asile on voit quelqu'un qui
viennent nous envahir
ce qui manque je dirais c'est le c'est
l'acceptation c'est la non-exclusion
c'est le fait de sentir qu'on est
un citoyen à part entière c'est ma vie
salut l'accueille qu'il a reçu en
arrivant au pays mais il voudrait lui
aussi que certaines perceptions changent
au bout des chiffres économiques ou des
défis d'emploi il y a des vies humaines
ces visuels c'est des parcours c'est des
histoires c'est des cultures c'est des
connaissances un peu plus de 5 ans après
avoir franchi le chemin Roxane love Joy
s'estime avoir trouvé sa patrie ici max
Isabelle Rochon Radio-Canada Montréal